today I am going to take a personality  test this one is the um how do you  pronounce that any  Enneagram the eniagram test  I make more significant contributions  than the average person well come on  I have a podcast so  I don't know how to put this but  I'm kind of a big deal the organizations  I belong to would not function well  without me  I'll tell you something this place would  fall apart if I wasn't doing YouTube  videos of myself taking personality  tests about myself  this whole building would crumble okay  people know me  if I'm honest I feel that I'm a bit  better than other people well  again as we've established  podcast host number one number two  other reasons I'm very important uh I  have  many leather-bound books